so transfer learning is when you
transfer your knowledge from one domain
to a new totally new domain and I think
that is the key to actually general
intelligence and that's the thing that
we as humans do amazingly well for
example I played so many board games now
when if someone was to teach me a new
board game I wouldn't be coming to that
fresh anymore I would know you know
straight away I could apply all these
different heuristics to that I've
learned from other games to this new one
even if I've never seen that before
and currently no machines can do that
and I think the key to doing transfer
learning is going to be conceptual
knowledge so abstract knowledge so these
so the acquisition of conceptual
knowledge that is abstracted away from
the perceptual details of where you
learnt it from so then you can go look
okay I'll apply it to this new domain so
I think that's actually one of the the
big challenges to be tackled towards
general AI